una aprobación marcada por las fuertes
discrepancias dentro del aparato
legislativo francés la asamblea nacional
respaldó con 118 votos a favor y 89 en
contra la denominada ley de vigilancia
sanitaria a cámara baja del parlamento
tuvo la última palabra sin haber llegado
a un consenso con el senado que rechazó
el texto
así las cosas el gobierno extiende el
estado de emergencia en el país hasta el
31 de julio y queda autorizado para
prorrogar la aplicación del pase
sanitario hasta dicha fecha
aún no hemos salido de esta crisis
sanitaria no es el momento de abandonar
las herramientas de salud que nos
permiten actuar y combatir contra el
virus los detractores de la norma cargan
contra las facultades especiales que
este estado de emergencia le permite al
gobierno y más teniendo en cuenta que
cobijará el periodo electoral del
segundo trimestre del próximo año
durante la primavera austral y carlton
with the moi llevamos meses advirtiendo
de los claros riesgos de perpetuar esta
manera de gerenciar recordemos queridos
colegas que después de los ataques
terroristas de 2015 el estado de
emergencia en términos de seguridad duró
y cuatro meses
en vigor desde julio el pase sanitario
es un documento imprescindible para
atender a los restaurantes bares eventos
deportivos y hasta para el transporte
público su aplicación despertó masivas
protestas a nivel nacional su actual
vigencia termina el 15 de noviembre y
pese a que actualmente cerca del 70% de
los habitantes ya tiene el esquema
completo de vacunación hay cifras que
alertan de un resurgir de la pandemia en
la última semana de octubre la tasa de
incidencia que mide el número de nuevos
contagios respecto a la población
aumentó en un 12% sobre la semana
anterior